this video is about to be very
uncomfortable for a lot of us it's very
uncomfortable for me to talk about but
we need to talk about it Aiden did a
very horrendous thing period Point Blank
we need pew pew reform in our country
but the way that the media and the
police are misgendering and dead naming
Aiden is quite concerning it's also
concerning that I had to go to the
telegraph from UK to actually get
Aiden's chosen name It's upsetting that
constantly it is she her pronouns that
is incredibly frustrating because even
though they did this
that's what's really upsetting wouldn't
you say
that's what's really frustrating so
what's really upsetting yeah yeah
he he did a bad thing that's what she's
saying she goes oh he did a bad thing
was really frustrating here
is that the newspapers won't pretend
that she's a man